على الانتقال الانتقال الى سرير او غرفه
منفصله عن شريك ليس بالامر غير المعتاد
ويعرف باسم الطلاق اثناء انه
انواع طبعا ابحاث حديثه مشاهدينا كشفت ان
بعض البشر ينامون بمفردهم بشكل افضل بكثير
وفقا لموقع ساينس
ووفقا لاستطلاع اجرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
عام 2023 على
2200 شخص من البالغين في الولايات المتحده
ينام واحد من كل خمسه ازواج الان في غرفه
النوم منفصله لبعض الوقت على الاقل وقال
اكثر من النصف بقليل ان النوم في عزله قد
يحسن نوعيه نومهم طبعا مصطلح طلاق النوم
لا يشير ابدا
للعداء بين الشريكين او الى انفصالهما لكن
الذين جربوه فعلوا ذلك لعده اسباب تشمل
التعارض في اوقات النوم او الحاجه الى
مساحه شخصيه اكبر او مشكله الشخير
على العموم مشاهدينا الزميله لميس ابراهيم
ستطلعن على امور اخرى ايضا تتعلق بتعكير
صفو
صحه الانسان الجسديه والعقليه لكن هناك
الكثير من الامور التي من شانها ان تعكر
صفو نومنا الضوء الازرق مثلا المنبعث من
شاشات الهواتف المحموله وبعض الاضاءه
المنزليه يسرق النوم من العين ليلا حيث
انه يجعل المرء ويمنعه من النعاس
النظر الى الساعه عند استيقظك في منتصف
الليل فالقلق من مشاهده الساعه يمكن ان
يبقيك مستيقظا لفتره اطول القيلوله اثناء
النهار فالغافوات التي تكون بعد الساعه
الثالثه مساء تحديدا يمكن ان تتداخل مع
فتره النوم في الليل تناول كميه كبيره من
الطعام قبل النوم يمكن ان يسبب انزعاجا في
المعده وكذلك يتداخل مع ايقاع الساعه
البيولوجيه للجسم ما يؤثر على نومنا درجه
حراره الغرفه اذا كانت مرتفعه ستلاحظ انك
تعاني حتى تخلد الى النوم قم بالتاكد من
درجه حراره الغرفه تتراوح بين 23 والعشرين
والخمسه عشر درجه مئويه قبل النوم
[موسيقى]
اسوا حاجه بتعكر صفو نومي لما المدام تخش
تصحيني عشان خاطر بتقول لي عايزه فلوس
جايه من الشغل تعبان بيلعبوا مع بعض
يهزروا صوتهم الراجل اللي
الطعام ده كل شويه بيعدي وبتاع فعلا مش
عارفه انام منه بقى
[موسيقى]
مثلا يبقى عليا فلوس طول ما انا عليا فلوس
ممكن ما اعرفش انام بقى بقيه الشعر كله مش
يوم ولا اثنين ولا ما اعرفش انا الوقت
يفكر كثير يا ابو علي هموم وعليه حكايات
فبيفكر في ايام الايه بكره عامه اخواتي
ساعات
هزار بقى مع ضحك ولعب وكده
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو اختصاصيه الصحه العامه
والامراض العصبيه الدكتور هشام القلعاني
دكتور هشام معنا الورد يا هلا صباح الخير
صباح الخير صباح الخير كل عام وانتم بخير
يعني وبتفهم هذه الدراسه غلط المشكله مش
بالضروره تكون بالشريك هو ما يعكر صفو
النوم ولكن اذا كان هناك شخير او بعض
العوامل اللي تحدثت عنها لميس قبل قليل
ممكن انه فعلا النوم بمفردنا يكون افضل
طيب يعني شو هي الاساسيات اللي لازم ننتبه
عليها في عندها النوم لحتى ننام بطريقه
افضل واعمق واكثر صحيه طبعا هي تعتمد على
الشركات كما تفضلتم فقد اشاره الدراسات
واخرها دراسه امريكيه بعض الازواج ينامون
بشكل افضل عند الانفصال عن السرير او في
غرفه منفصله دون التاثير على الحياه
الزوجيه انا طول عمري يعني بس طول عمري
بشعر انه هذا يعني احد المؤثرات السلبيه
على العلاقه لما يصير في انفصال او الطلاق
زي كما يقال بالمقابل نتائج اخرى للدراسات
بينت ان الحياه الزوجيه تزيد من جوده
النوم لدى الزوجين التي كانت ما قبل
الزواج حيث تزيد الشعور في الامان تزيد
الطمانينه تزيد السعاده وتسرع الدخول في
النوم العميق طبعا النوم العميق بها
المرحله الرابعه من النوم او يمن تسمى
بمرحله الاحلام الشخص الطبيعي يحتاج 90
دقيقه حتى يصل الى هذه المرحله وهذه
المرحله هي الحاء التي نحتاجها لتخزين
المعلومات التي ثقناها اثناء النهار وخاصه
بالنسبه للطلاب هذه المرحله هي ام مرحله
في النوم يجب الوصول اليها بالتالي كلما
كانت نوعيه النوم موجوده النوم افضل كلما
انعكس بشكل ايجابي على الحياه وخاصه
الحياه الزوجيه هل المقصود بهذه الدراسه
دكتور انه هناك مثلا اشخاص يجي يسالك يا
فلان انت نايم لا يعني ما انت بسابع نومه
فلما يجي يسالك هل هي المقصود فيها انه
مقاطعه هذه الوتيره من
المراحل التي تدخلك في النوم ام انه عقلك
الباطن وانت نايم يفكر بالشخص اللي جنبك
باشياء خارجه تمام هلق النوم في يجب
التركيز على امرين نوعيه النوع ومده النوم
او جوده النوم طبعا النوم المتقطع كما
يعادل عدم النوم في النوم هناك اربع مراحل
هذا الخوف من الشريك هناك اربع مراحل
والنوم الخفيف المرحله الثانيه هالنوم
الاعمق ثم مرحله حركات العين اللا سريعه
ثم الرابع هي مرحله الاحلام وهي مرحله
النوم المجدي بالتالي هناك تسلسل زمني
للوصول الى هذه المراحل وجود القلق كما
ذكرت استاذ عادل او التفكير الزائد يمنع
الدخول او الشخير او وجود مقاطعه لتسلسل
النوم احد الازواج يفضل النوم في غرفه
يكون الضوء موجود ضمن الغرفه الزوجه الاخر
يفضل ظلام مطلق
تمام فهي من احد الاسباب تساعد في تخفيف
من نوعيته وجوده النوم بالاضافه طبعا
القلق والتوتر والحاله الاجتماعيه التي
تتزوجين هناك ايضا عامل فيزيولوجي كلما
تقدم الانسان في العمر تقل نوعيه النوم
كبار السن يحتاجون فتره اطول للدخول في
النوم
ويصبح النوم لديهم متقطع بشكل اكثر
طيب دكتور قرات مره في انه افضل يعني
الدماغ لا يفرز هرمون النوم الميلتون الا
اذا كان في ظلام دامس هل هاي حقيقه فعليه
لانه في كثير ناس ما بيقدروا يناموا الا
اذا كان في زي ما انت ذكرت ضوء يعني خفيف
في الغرفه تماما فعلا هو هرمون يفرز من
الغده الصنوبريه هو هرمون النوم وهو مسؤول
عن تنظيم دوره النوم وفعلا هو يحتاج الى
ظلام داكن ويبدا افرازه قبل ثلاث ساعات من
بدء النوم بالتالي الاشخاص
بظلام دامس او كاحل يعني قبل قبل ما تدخل
هنا انسي راويه الاعاده بالتالي هناك شخص
متعود الذهاب الى سري في الساعه الحاديه
عشر ليلا يوميا
الجسم بشكل تلقائي بدءا من الساعه الثامنه
مساء يبدا حتى يشعر بالنعس في الساعه
الحاديه عشر ليلا بالتالي الاشخاص الذين
يعانون من تبدل في نمط هناك طبيعه العمل
فيها مناوبات او تبدل في اوقات العمل
يعانون صعوبه انه هو السبب ان الجسم تعود
على اطلاق هذا الهرمون في ساعه معينه ثم
في اليوم التالي او في الاسبوع التالي
تغير الموعد
اليوم حينما نتحدث ايضا عن هذا الطلاق
السريري خلينا نتكلم عن الميزات بانه لا
يكون شخص اخر معك يشاركك ذات السرير فيكون
النوم جوده اعلى هل بالضروره ان يكون ذلك
ام لا انه وجود الشريك في السرير قد يعطيك
نوم اعمق بالراحه بالالفه اكثر تمام استاذ
عادل الدراسه الامريكيه للشملات عدد كبير
من الازواج حوالي 22 اشارت هناك ربع
الازواج زادت نوعيه النوم بالنوم بجانب
الشريك بسبب وجود الشعور بالطمانينه
الشعور بالسعاده القلق
اما في المقابل هناك نسبه معينه بسبب
عوامل اجتماعيه او عوامل العضويه واهم او
اشياء هي الشخير اي والله مزعج يعني انا
بس بدي اقول شغله قبل ما ننهي بانه وحتى
طبعا لازم ننتبه بانه النوم الليل ابدا لا
يضاهي او النوم النهار لا يضاه نوم بالليل
ولا يعوضه باي شكل من الاشكال شكرا جزيلا
لك اختصاصي الصحه العامه والامراض العصبيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات